[Music]
[Music]
two basketballs are not enough to call
this scene out for over basketballing
but it is two too many basketballs for a
high school hallway without the
accompanying teacher yelling for them to
put those in a locker i wonder if now
that kamal is all confident and stuff
she'll realize that she can break this
pattern of perfectly timed high school
hallway bullsh by simply arriving a
minute earlier or two minutes later what
makes you think you have airmen powers
because we're about charming and we look
a lot younger than we are marvel thinks
that its introduction of the multiverse
makes it okay to steal jokes from our
universe about paul rudd's abnormal and
completely unfair genetics i heard zoe's
follower count like quadrupled this
weekend and now we enter the opposite
side of the hallway where the tunnel of
exposition is already in progress this
qr code works yes i'm giving that a sin
because it leads us to a site where
marvel teases free content while also
dangling in front of us another paid
subscription service which i'm probably
signing up for because i'm absolutely
loving the show so the sin is me being
incapable of not giving my money to
marvel and disney being incapable of not
taking it and then all of a sudden there
was all this screaming and i was thrown
to the ground how how do you forget that
you were slammed by thor's hammer how do
you forget that also you know all those
times in life where you stand shoulder
to shoulder with your friends for a
protracted period of time so everyone
has to turn their necks 90 degrees to
engage in the conversation and the
camera can film everyone from the same
angle yeah neither do i so who was it uh
night light show is leaning hard into
its portrayal of superheroes of
celebrities in this reality so it stands
to reason that kamal is an up and coming
star what doesn't make sense is that zoe
would feel the need to make up this name
on the spot that would be like us naming
courtney cox nightlight when we saw her
for the first time in cocoon to return i
don't know guys it's hard for me to take
scenes like this seriously when there
are people positioned behind zoe who are
only able to stare directly at the back
of her head as if that is somehow normal
i see we're sticking with the 17 logos
theme in episode 2 which means i
suddenly feel obligated to send this
again but i don't like being obligated
to sin so this sin is for the pressure
to sin in my determination to break free
by sending it anyway which somehow
brings me a sense of control therapy for
the win i'm going to point out that if
the school has any budget issues they
might want to consider turning unneeded
lights off in unused parts of the
building like this one
i guess we wouldn't truly be backstage
in a high school theater if this random
assortment of easily toppled items
wasn't set up and ready to fall at the
slightest nudge featuring this beautiful
mural by b-mike would have earned this
show a sin off or it not for the fact
that it's in atlanta and not jersey city
okay no super strength all i got is this
being mildly dissatisfied with just one
superpower so it looks like your power
isn't coming from the bank show wants
you to know that you'll do none of this
and more on your microsoft surface does
this look like some kind of writing
looks like arabic or
urdu i don't know if only the teenage
smart guy who somehow managed to scan
your body and interpret all sorts of
graphs on a tablet could also take a
photo of this writing and feed it into a
piece of technology that would
immediately google translate it again
the show says new jersey when the
skyline says georgia you have to let me
go
as the saying goes pride comes before
the fall from an inconsequential height
that you concealed with a deceiving
camera angle to artificially create
tension despite the fact that we all
know you're not gonna harm the main
character in any meaningful way in the
second episode of the series
also super good thing that not one
person is looking through all these
windows at the highly suspect
shenanigans happening in broad daylight
beating pipes does not make water come
out faster beating pipes makes it worse
when you're so brand loyal that you feel
the need to correct your elders in the
masjid but still can't be bothered to
use the entire name of said brand
you really gotta fix this place
uh
no you mean i gotta fix our section of
this place it's clear the scene is
trying to make a point about unequal
distribution of resources but audio
feedback is loud terrible and should be
heard all throughout this room not just
in one section sisters no talking during
the lecture please because of course our
favorites get in trouble for whispering
even though the selfie sisters were so
loud just a moment ago selective hearing
that drives the plot is selective and
the mosque thief has struck again
writers think i won't immediately become
more interested in the case of the shoe
thief than i am in the main plot that is
the 22nd pair of shoes that have been
stolen so go with me here maybe stop
wearing expensive desirable shoes to a
place where people keep stealing them
thanks for coming miguel's hovering who
the [ __ ] is miguel what's up
you want some is there alcohol on that
nah it's just orange juice who the [ __ ]
is this kid and why is he offering
random people his orange juice and why
is kamal accepting his orange juice and
why does the scene feel like a
meaningful lesson about not trusting
drinks from strangers wrapped in a
contrived coming of age trope and why do
i feel like adding a sin even though i
agree with the message
i was gonna send the attractive
character sexily emerges from water
cliche but i'm gonna pivot to the
starstruck character standing on
clothing that is needed by waterlogged
hottie cliche because it's just so
annoying when it happens
did did she just pull a drink out of the
freezer i think she just pulled a drink
out of a freezer this is one of the most
clever ways i've seen texting visualized
on screen it reminds me of just how well
this show makes use of effects like this
to tell kamala's story and give her
world a fun and youthful aesthetic
kamala agrees to driving lessons without
checking with her parents first is that
allowed kids are terrifying spend six
weeks on ancient rome in ancient greece
but six minutes on ancient persia and
byzantium nakia would be the marvelous
miss marvel at world history sins hey
kikka are you feeling all right kamala
can't stop glowing which i fail to see
the issue with but the show presents it
as a problem that can't be solved
without first confirming that she's
tried to take the bengal off or that she
even still has it on for that matter i
know how weird your mom can get about
tampons tampons oh come on it's not like
people believe they get lost in your
bloodstream or something
wait they did okay well it's not like
some people believe you lose your
virginity to them or something
oh they do fine at least we all know
they're made from cotton candy
wait what okay well then this sin is for
ridiculous misunderstandings about
tampons
i mean she does have another hand if she
wanted to carry on the cycle ruse and
reach for it de-stress after school best
thing you can do
drive in jersey city show wants me to
believe that it believes there are roads
in the tri-state area designed in any
way to help someone de-stress without
having a full-on panic attack maybe
someday you'll feel like jersey's your
home jersey
this is comrade he's our cousin this
works the british left us with a mess my
exact statement after eating lunch with
ian somehow makes it into the script hey
there's a story about muniba's family
that i quickly need to talk about
because it's important to the plot so
stand by while i expose it a little for
the audience
i wait for the post every day yeah i'll
get on that boldface lying to your
elders but no i've spoken too much
already no no i'm not going to talk
about this at all is someone who once
received an electric massager from their
grandparents i'm aware that certain
presents should never be acknowledged or
discussed but nani refusing to talk
about the family heirloom she just
gifted kamala seems more about drawing
out the story and less about things
people actually do
i don't have a mango man in the scene
something wrong the voices on the phone
could be heard in the hallway aways from
the door mr khan bangs on the door when
he opens it he believes that kamala is
just asleep are the men in this show
just dumb after that we will mobilize
the sunday school teachers help
infiltrate the institute fine don't
explain what incriminating evidence has
given the teachers leverage over the
insta click but at least tell me why are
these teens always ordering groceries
technically the reverts but to do that
you have to make it past the mini girls
what have they been sworn to protect the
reverts for some reason even then it
looks like they're really into running
around a bunch so getting past them is
probably just a matter of waiting until
they're out of your way the illuminantes
i'll talk to them i mean sure go
directly to the aunties but wasn't the
whole point of the last scene to go to
specific groups first to get a greater
chance at the aunties and if not then
why show us the previous progression of
the political plan at all i have to go
after my white whale character uses
everyone's favorite literary reference
for something difficult cliche as nikia
presses for a vote i'm reminded that too
many people use the political knuckle
pointing gesture thing it's distracting
and i'm so focused on it that i can't
even hear anything important being said
oh she's talking about women's rights oh
no worries we don't have to worry about
anything changing there right right i'm
not sure where to get anything on this
plate in that is a [ __ ] sin because
it looks delicious
is this about the party that's a strange
question to ask when the first question
should be where are my parents i heard
she killed a man dead uh yes killing one
does mean they are dead i never
understand why anyone says kill the man
dead as if there are other options not
figuring out what filter setting to use
prior to selfieing yourself out a window
so that the writers could cook up a
scenario requiring our resident hero to
intervene in summation even as a
narrative device the sin here is still
kids how did anyone get this shot at eye
level as kamala did a ridiculous
three-point superhero landing
given the way he lands on each of these
things as he blinks his way to the
ground it makes sense if he said my face
my back my ribs or even my ass but my
ankle how the [ __ ] did that happen she
wants us to believe that no one here not
even scowls mcgee saw comrade zoom in
with his uncle's whip pick up kamala and
speed away i'd like you to be my mom
damn kamron you've only been on one date
and the next thing i know i am barefoot
on a new york city sidewalk in the
middle of summer wait what makes you
think you have airmen powers i ate six
muffins downstairs a while ago and my
cholesterol level is 305. this girl
shows up breaks into my house takes the
lantern blasts me
and suddenly she's best friends with
that
saying she's a superhero's daughter
and we're just supposed to believe it
all without question
now it comes to it i don't feel like
partying with it it's mine i found it it
came to me rudolph please could you tone
it down a bit that knows that beautiful
wonderful nose
one
very cute
and
chanel you're in desperate need of
chanel hello
what'd you do jump ship
what
what's with the life preserve
remember the time you were working with
um what was the name hot spot topic of
course freaking hot topic that explains
everything how do you feel about our
first dance as a husband and wife being
to living on a prayer patrick has a
terrible idea